hey guys this is andrew for trading
sensors.com so i've been working as a
professional trader for the past
six years in hong kong and i've decided
a few months ago to create
my youtube channel because i want to
show you all the different tools and
techniques that i use at work that work
for me
i'm going to show you how to use it
yourself so training
is mostly about so of course technical
analysis but also
analyzing the data and to read the flows
so basically this is what technical
analysis is as well you just do it a
different way
so if you want to know about all the
stuff you guys are in the right place
so in today's video i want to make an
update on gamestop
let's get into it
[Music]
so we had you know a pretty tough week
on gamestop
so this is i'm on the four hours time
frame once again guys the four hours
time frame
is for me the best time frame to use
because it's both
used by professional investors like
long-term institutional clients
and some short-term traders that just do
some buy and sell orders every day
so this time frame gives you a lot of
signals and those signals are for me
no more trustful than the signals you
can find for example
the hourly timeframe anyway so here the
situation
is so this was the big drop we had you
know minus 30
this was the huge rebound we had just
right after
and i told you guys that this kind of
stuff you know it
it takes time to be fixed you know there
was a lot of damage that was created
that day
you know a lot of fear that was in the
market and i know that this fear
is coming again because the price action
was bearish for the past like this was
march
the past 10 days you know the past two
weeks but
from a technical analysis perspective we
are bullish guys we are bullish look at
that
i'm on the forward time frame once again
the most
used moving average is the 200 period
moving average you can use it uh the
simple one
or the exponential weighted one which
just gives more importance to the recent
past i like to use the simple ones but
you can do
just use the ones that have the best
reactions and you can see that we are
trading above this 200 period moving
average so this is
the first thing to show you when you
take a step back
that we are in the bullish price action
now
if i go on the shorter term guys i
showed you this
triangle that i was seeing here so
triangles usually
occur in force waves of idiot wave
development
but they also can appear on the second
wave so to me
the counting i was making here so here i
have my correction in abc and i was
seeing a one two three four five
coming right now once again on the short
term
i have this triangle and what happened
the last
four hours of the market on friday
is not nice guys i don't like this last
candle because
it is closing below the
basis of my triangle which is not good
but once again guys to have
a breakout you need to have two
consecutive candles that are trading
below your support level here i have
only one
so this could be a fake breakout if the
first candle
on monday closes above this 160
to level so this is what we are looking
for this is what you guys want to see
on the first four hours of training on
monday now second thing
that is uh interesting is once again so
as you can notice
we are we rebounded just above
this 200 premium moving average that
acted as support
so it's gonna keep acting as support on
the bit longer term
so basically this is a bit the safety
liner and yes the 150
250 level roughly will act probably as
support again on monday so we can have
maybe
a bearish opening but the first four
hours will be very important
then last thing i wanted to show you is
that the volumes
have not kicked off yet guys all right
so i go back on a daily time frame
because the volumes are more clear
so once again don't focus at all my
drawings guys i will come back to it
once we're gonna break this triangle on
the upside i
still believe it strongly let's see of
course you know this is only one
scenario what could happen is that we go
lower and you know we have an
x y z you know it's a different type of
correction when you have three abc
this is possible as well but for now
this is not what is happening
if this happens probably we're going to
revisit the 110
level but once again guys this is not
what
is happening right now right now we are
bullish
and what i wanted to show you is the
volumes guys look at
the weak volumes that we had once again
the volume
refers to the number of people that
agreed
upon a price and you can see that not
that many people agree on the price we
had the
past 10 days i mean people don't trade
all right people wait
people hold people are waiting for some
information or some uh you know moves
some flaws whatever they're waiting for
they are
waiting and when when the volumes are
going to kick off
and if then we don't have this bullish
price action that i expect
it means you know things are actually
happening
a different way that i was thinking but
for now the volumes are low
we are correcting i told you guys that
this would probably take one or two
weeks
it's been 10 days we have a big week
coming uh with the expiry on the 16th of
april
that is huge once again you know just
every month the first
month's expiry is huge but what i see on
this expiry is a lot of
upside calls that i bought every day you
know
so this is telling me that the
bullishness is still in
this market last thing i wanted to
tell you guys so let me go back on the
four hours
so here for now the strangle is holding
all right fake breakout
so let's see what we have on monday and
the level you want to break out
on the upside is the 180 all right
if we trade above 180 for more than four
hours i mean eight hours i mean two
candles consecutive candles
this is the signal guys that it's
starting and once it's starting i showed
you
my scenario it's like you know very
bullish
so that's it for me i hope you guys
enjoyed this video and if you did
please don't forget to click on the sub
like and bell button
so you're going to be the first to know
when i upload anything new
and stay close to show i see you guys